إنه لامع ، إنه مستدير ،
به فتحة في الوسط طريًا
من الداخل
مقرمشًا من الخارج إذا كنت تعتقد
أنه ليس مجرد خبز قديم جيد ،
فأنت مخطئ
وأن هذا الخبز الأسطوري ساعد الصين على
الفوز بالحرب
قبل 500 عام
[  الموسيقى]
لذا كيف يمكن للخبز أن يقود بلدًا إلى
النصر في المعركة ، قد تطلب ذلك
لمعرفة أننا قمنا بزيارة مخبز في fuon
china
حيث يتخصص السيد Huang وعائلته
في صنع guangbang
[الموسيقى]
[الموسيقى
] العام 1563. الصين تكافح
للدفاع عن نفسها ضد القراصنة اليابانيين
كل ليلة ، كان القراصنة اليابانيون
يتسللون من قواربهم ويأخذون كل ما في
وسعهم من جيش الجنرال تشي
قبل أن يلاحظ الجيش أن
اليابانيين قد اختفوا
بطريقة ما ، وكان القراصنة يعرفون بالضبط مكان
تمركز جيش الجنرال في
كل مرة يتضح ذلك  كانت
النيران المستخدمة لطهي وجباتهم
[موسيقى]
يمكنهم طهي هذا الخبز في
فرن طيني تحت الأرض
حتى يتمكن الجنود من إعداد الطعام
دون الكشف عن
موقعهم وتلك الحفرة في المنتصف  القبعة
موجودة حتى يتمكن الجنود من إخراج
الخبز ليحملوه حول أعناقهم ، وهذا صحيح ،
وهو عبارة عن عقد خبز ،
مما خلق طعامًا محمولاً
لن يبطئ من سرعته أثناء الكمين
وتعيش الأسطورة بفضل
الخبازين المحليين الذين يواصلون صنع
guangbang  بالطريقة التقليدية
بمجرد ثقب الفتحة المميزة في الوسط ،
يتم لصق كل قطعة من العجين
داخل فرن طيني يتم
تسخينه بالفحم ،
يمكنك تناولها كساندويتش إفطار
مع البيض مع حشوات لحم الخنزير لتناول طعام الغداء
أو ببساطة مع البصل الأخضر وبراعم الفاصوليا
بالنسبة لوجبة خفيفة مغذية ،
مهما كان اختيارك ، فهو
لذيذ أيضًا
[موسيقى] ،
لذا يمكنك معرفة كيف أصبح
التكتيك العسكري للفوز بالحرب
وجبة خفيفة محببة ، كل ذلك بفضل
الجنرال تشي